je relève le défi
salut c'est jennifer salut cellou et on
est en direct du doublage du dessin
animé maya l'abeille 2 les jeux du miel
j'étais très heureuse de retrouver maya
pourquoi est-ce que tu ne nous laissent
pas tranquille
rira bien qui rira le dernier après la
grande finale de demain une grande
bouffée d'oxygène doublé des dessins
animés c'est un réel saisi beaucoup
d'amusement une grande récréation et en
même temps on apprend violette elle est
toute nouvelle
je dirais que si une abeille très maline
voilà ce qu'on va faire je te promet de
laisser tranquille tu as précieuse
équipe des coquelicots
si tu arrives à me battre à la colline
aux limaces maintenant c'était ma vraie
première expérience mon personnage alors
maya l'abeille tout le monde connaît
maya l'abeille c'est à dire qu'elle est
multi générationnel il est mis au goût
du jour
il est modernisé le personnage et
modernisé au tube love you vu que le
modèle historique il ya toujours cette
petite morale quelle jolie à l'issue de
ce genre de dessin animé c'est ce que
j'aime chez mayence est ce qu'on aime
toucher magna et je trouve que que ça
traverse comme ça tout les toutes les
générations
[Musique]
c'est le personnage très attachant dont
mg maya de tous ces traits de caractère
qu'on adore retrouver chez maya et en
même temps elle apprend la notion d'
équipes donc à travers tous ces nouveaux
personnages laval se rend compte qu'on
n'est plus voir ensemble à quoi
on va tout faire pour gagner cette coupe
[Musique]